and we are live with a new mic that
works so I won't be missing to show any
more kind of building will be kind of
neat that the last word with Laura
kognito and ebon tiss has returned how
are you doing sir I'm doing good doing
good glad I can actually hear you not
sounded like you're talking through
weird weird connections man yeah it was
it was real spooky man and I heard cuz
like we were trying to get up early we
like we had a whole thing you had it you
know a plan that you had to leave early
too much almost started a little earlier
I can't go and I was all ready to go and
then drivers and bad chords and
randomness and I'm like oh man it was
good to be back good to be back at the
campfire boy do we have a lot to discuss
yeah your mic going out I mean I had to
be out of town so we didn't have a big
winner to do it but we were like hanging
it was up at like 6 o'clock in the
morning people are like oh my god what
are you doing up this early we trying to
get it in and the mic goes out cuz man
the day before they just started just
rolling info out just just starting
craziness so without too much
introduction besides the fact they
didn't finish my majestic set last night
so first one is done I was out of town
and now they're gonna change it but I
was like you you master looked I said
majestic Almagest ok I'll go no I wanted
to get the majestic done before next
week because their throne is this week
so I figure if I'll do one of those
that's the one we'll probably do make
for a good stream or something like that
mmm but overall got some thoughts about
their put just put a video up about that
one also make sure the stream is not
going crazy right now
yeah streams catch up hold on just looks
like yeah sorta kinda seems good
sometimes just has occasional moments so
alright yeah we got a whole bunch of in
vote Trump in the last week this was on
the first right before I left and we had
technical difficulties but we're gonna
go through kind of things in
chronological order from last week throw
we got in for this week and tois band
what's
and drop in so first thing kind of want
to get your thoughts I know other people
have put their thoughts about it out
there but we're just a little late to
the party shadow keep coming out on
October 1st instead of the 17th kind of
want to get your your tinfoil thoughts
your opinions and if you care don't care
and why you think it happened and what
do you think they might be working on in
that interim so I'm gonna drop it to you
first sir I was the juicy well from last
week but um no surprise cuz it was a
first we we're not used to delays so to
speak usually in that September the
window but um I loved it man
I'll be honest you know first thing that
came to mind was you cuz I was like okay
I know I know but he say you know like
this let it lit take their time and I'm
with you I'm literally with you II lay
it's it's literally two weeks you know I
mean but at the end of the day it's two
weeks that's needed and then we all know
again because of moorlands Monster
Hunter gears September's crowded not
that destiny was scared anybody just for
the record you have to put this out
there cuz I let I've been seeing some
reddit then I don't know if it was dizzy
slow like a slow its seasick slow-mo
start with me already see look at the
start trouble but here's the day not
that anybody was scared because we did
put the gauntlet out first that we were
gonna drop in that week and really
antagonize some situations and trust me
with cross saver I was very confident
but the reality is look a lot of people
want to play board lands we was out
there at a Cardian kong and um you know
huge huge presence a lot of desti fans
are Borland's fans they want to play it
so let us rock out we did a good a
chance to rock out a little bit but
ultimately I just think it just needed
just a little bit more time and I'm
completely fine with it even if they
would have said mid-october late October
I would have been fine with it because
the biggest thing in my opinion is
crossfade getting bumped up when they
said that last week I said oh nice just
lost here for a sec there when you said
that okay we're back I said I said
that's just blow was softened when we
got cross play a bit
save bumped up yeah that to me is the
the thing that's the deal so for me no
issues at all where do you stand on your
first initial reaction when you heard it
oh I mean for me it just opens up
September I mean whether it's whether
the reasons behind it or not just as a
just a gamer in general as we joked
about September before having complete
and total insanity
monster hunter World Borderlands 3 which
actually now have a chance to try which
I'm kind of excited about because
honestly I wasn't gonna jump in because
it was like four days for a brand new
series for me because I haven't played
the other two wasn't gonna be enough
time and then we're gonna be deep in
this one code vein comes out and so I
mean Link's Awakening whatever you want
there's a lot of stuff in there if you
want to dabble in something else before
you get into your destiny grind now you
get time to mess with one or two of
those for at least a little while which
is cool now some things people have been
saying it's like you've got some of the
Destiny community that were they started
doing Borderlands cthe a lien Broman
stuff like that
I mean honestly for some of them it's
like some people had joked around saying
it's like Bungie I'd like I have this
like contract with Borderlands that I
need to play this thing for like three
or four or five days you're kind of
messing with my time here it's like I'm
wondering if honestly I don't think they
were scared of Borderlands now is it
smart to move I think it's good for both
properties because yes as both
properties have some similar player
bases some similar streamers you're
gonna get a good push for one you know
two weeks the in the Internet is like an
eternity and you get a good push for the
other one so the spacing I think is
going to be a good thing for all of
those reasons whether streamers actually
get a little more time to satisfy their
obligations whether there's less rusher
and all those pieces and honestly it's
also just proof that they can decide to
release things when they want to if they
need things a couple week it's their
choice and I think that's the other
thing that I was like I loved it I was
like it's their choice to say is it two
weeks now for me and my head I go let's
go alright two weeks how much he
actually gonna get done in two weeks no
no no this is my this is where
lieutenant a hat comes on okay I don't
care I don't care if it's like two
months one month like but two weeks is a
max of one sprint 100 but it's like I
wonder lake okay so one of the things
that I know they probably want more time
for is cross save they want to give that
a solid month instead of like a couple
weeks to make sure that's completely
smooth because new light has to hit the
ground perfect as good as it can
yeah so a couple more weeks for that is
really good but the other side of things
is like how much do you really really
get done in two weeks because you're not
gonna implement a new system change
anything there's no thing major
happening in these two weeks I can
promise you this is polish developer
talking is this developer wager I would
wager developer has spoken my assumption
would be this is only gonna fill testing
balancing and just a little bit of QA
time there is no major system you're
gonna implement in the last two weeks
and you and if they wanted another
system it would be later that is my
hunch I'm gonna roll with you on that
I'm gonna run or Mele I would fight but
I'm gonna roll with you with this so so
give me the telephone is so being that
you feel that nothing substance
substantial can happen in to why the
bleed why not just keep the cadence like
they normally do so they will never say
it we get some donuts inside scoop here
is a big boy this is a school good no
honestly they'll never say it because
it's not in their place but I think
whether they whether you know they want
to just like distance themselves from
Borderlands 3 whether they want her to
move I don't think it's a hundred
percent but I would say I would say
somewhere in the realm of leg I would
say somewhere there on the forty to
fifty no it's not fear yeah I think it's
smarter for both and I think it's
somebody there saying two weeks pacing
it's like Borderlands is big we're gonna
be big we have new light we have stayed
here we have all that stuff but if you
smash it for days together with a raid
race with them them getting in the end
game both things competing I think they
did took the smarter independ
decision to say hey let's give ourselves
some space so you really feel this is
what I'm saying I would say it's about
half and that's half of them saying no
let's get a full month on our belt with
cross save let's get one more cycle of
testing let's get one more sequence of
like one last little patch like let's
give ourselves that little bit bigger
window we're doing too close to call of
duty which is still you know it's called
a baby but we can distance ourselves
into a different month I think it's a
combination of all those things yeah but
I don't think any of those things can be
discounted to be like no it's not
Borderlands I'm like there's no way they
look at that day and they're like no we
don't care about them I'm like no
because people move out of the way from
Red Dead and this is the first thing in
seven years for Borderlands and it's not
gonna be small so correct correct I
don't have to counterpoint um
go nuts oh I will smite under
speculation guys I have no no freaking
Blissett nothing you're saying is really
incorrect we're all speculating we don't
know right but I think there were only
reason why I tend to believe they hit a
kind of a snag somewhat is because let's
be real when we were first heard the
announcement and we were like September
17 cuz I was convinced II remember I was
the one running scared I was like do not
drop next to boil it stay away I was
like I took my table to my CEO no ego
evolved keep move your release date so
when they came out the gate and they
said boom 17 boom CrossFit I said oh and
then I get across st. at that time being
announced at that launch date the
initial launch day I'm like I don't care
what Portland is doing they can't
survive that and remember that the
public swell like people were hype at
that announcement like people were like
hey just got a couple days before lands
then then we go we go do what we got to
do so it's interest I mean it's very
interesting to me you know what happened
they it could be a very well thing what
you said internally maybe PR said
looking at st. really the smartest thing
you
also you know Luke maybe get back say
hey we still got a play test it's a
couple of kings or maybe they say hey
you know what because of everything
involved with cross save let's move it
away from that let's get everybody
acclimated and then release it so who
knows but it is in trend this is a very
love to be the fly on the wall it's just
like yeah it's like I mean there's
there's all I think the big thing is you
can't make it one single factor there's
a lot of fact you go into all this and
thence the biggest pieces there's no one
single thing making this decision
they're like okay we are still a game
publisher of our own now we do know
there's a big you know behemoth coming
out pretty close we may need a little
bit more time cross save is gonna be a
bit like all those little things they're
their thing so we got it we got it we
got major playing in chat right now
shout out to the do 70 dive and that's
my god he said I actually love boy lands
despite Randy Pitchford and what rush I
don't keep drops Orlan three will be on
the show you can say in the bushes it's
fine I like that
I like the shot the Shelf is a little
higher brow you do this by game thank
you guys for tuning in live if you are
in catching this live we're live on
twitch.tv slash Yvonne tests you guys
know about the archives and the audio
and stuff like that it's out there on
every place you can look this thing up
but catching it live is always fun so
thank you guys for tuning in this wasn't
the anomaly announcement we got that day
so we know about the delay they wanted a
little more time cool alright what else
is happening
well the raid so garden of salvation is
the names before it sets the game we
want to know what your thoughts on the
name are cuz we're going from we're
going into back into the black garden
which was like this beating weird
massive vex madness and now we're going
back into the garden of salvation with a
much more positive spin so scaris what
you thought about just that name alone I
always loved I love these things when
they they kind of we just get a name
snippet right it's so cool well clearly
black gaudiya clearly um I'm still
feeling vex or you know or something to
that effect
but um I don't know man again is it's so
cuz last time when I was trying to put
together a crown of sorrows I couldn't
even you know saying get that one
together like they they they have very
good they're very good at cryptic names
yeah
whether it's still you get a little
piece but you still gotta gotta put it
together
um I literally do not know he like this
is one I am stumped I do not know you
know we had Queen on and we kind of
visited this topic before and it just
seems that it's definitely gonna spin a
different direction it's definitely
almost like a I'm getting a forsaken
vibe where remember you know when we
play for sick it was all about parents
barons barons avenge avenge Kade and
then the beauty that was the dream in
city okay so I don't know if we're gonna
get something on that level because we
obviously they saying it's not as big as
for this is gonna be rise of our level
but I do sense a thematic change post
eros post or whatever the name is yeah
post campaign yes something's gonna
happen that's the vibe I'm going with
well what do you what do you go with no
I mean kind of the same you got Garden
of salvation it's so I don't know if
it's like I mean salvation are we I
don't know I mean we're dealing with
supposedly got nightmares and phantasms
and all this stuff in the campaign the
campaign with eros and we're gonna face
the you know versions of crota and Gaul
and things we've seen before so the
thing is like what did we awaken and
then what are we act is is that are they
actually gonna connect the campaign to
this raid boss that is through this
index portal like sending out these
phantasms or from the Black Card and
creating I don't know I mean it's like
there's a whole lot of weird speculation
but the names interesting I was kind of
like the names but salvation gives it
like I mean salvation you're asking
first salvation for is this heiress of
salvation are we saving her from
something like I don't know so it could
be interesting but I'm hoping at least
one way or the another interesting crazy
whatever connected to the campaign
that's all ass cuz you said I don't know
if this is gonna be like you know a
tangled Shore to dreaming city but if
it's you know moon into crap the garden
of salvation raid some connection we go
through a portal to get I don't know but
I'd like
a connect without because shout out the
screen he said bury the vex we're
guarding a blackguard
oh boy he's done is he's in his bag
right now oh yeah yeah scream is got the
tinfoil hat realize he's he's got it ah
well the other nice is your date this is
September or October sorry October 5th
on a Saturday and contest will be active
first weekend Raider ace what do you
think love it love it man give us some
damn time give us some damn time to
enjoy you know sometimes you know much
as we love the new content and stuff
like that you know it comes speedball
through it and we know what the vibe I'm
getting now is now that they've done
that new worlds first rules they'll be
still some yeah there will still be
something in place I don't think people
are gonna be like am sadly now I could
be MaxLite and whatever whatever if I
grind crazy no they don't just will be
there so yeah so definitely contents
gonna be there um cannot wait to see you
know what's going on with that but I
like having a couple days I don't mind
I'd be actually Saturday you know it's
kind of cool you get more people and you
get more of a demographic that is
actually home you know I'm saying and
can play the game and try to enter you
get a bigger turnout so I love it you
know I'm not necessarily the biggest
fake let's be real like unless you've
got a weird job when you just take off
like I could work like a psychopath like
me whenever a huge dlc of destiny I I am
NOT no shame I get my boss knows is I'm
sick that I'm sick I'm available that's
the case I had to take Kings sickness I
had to for city's sake every major
September I come down something so you
know allergies some goes on around that
time I like it I like it a lot and I'm
pumped man what about you good evening
you like this uh I mean I'm with you
it's like Haileybury said it well it's
like it definitely gives people more
chain
again they're in the 24 hour run if
you're going for that it's on a weekend
so it's not like a 24 hours or if I do
take Tuesday you got six hours of
grinding again 24 hours through
Wednesday two days off in the middle of
the week gets like no it can be a
Saturday it can be a Sunday then you can
be a zombie sleep and still go to work
the next day and kind of have and make
it but if you want to put that 24 hour
grind in then you actually can now the
question is do you think they'll do you
think he'll just start at reset like
start at 10:00 o'clock Pacific like
their usual reset time is that just when
you think he'll be alive yeah I think
they would go earlier I think they'll
stay consistent we reset that seems to
be their mo I can't see them breaking
that but oh yeah we still got a couple
days to play out play out of content
enjoy and then man can I cannot wait bro
let's go me it's gonna be sick so the
other piece I guess would think do you
think this is telling them the size of
content because forsaken was 10 10 days
yeah I mean instead of three they're
doing it a weekend for four but not it's
not that full week two level an
experienced angled Shore in the Dreaming
city and a Senate challenges and all
these things it's you know four days and
then we get back get then we get into
the right do you think the scale of
content that we're gonna get is
reflected in that time scale mmm good
question
so one extent to an extent I would agree
with you I would say um if it was
forsaking levels they probably realized
it would try to be no way for us to I
think they have a good gauge of
understanding our grind they know our
levels and again they were very
transparent remember y'all this is still
season past content technically but this
is a rise of iron bite-sized chunk in
the first go with season of the undying
so um yeah I think I'm expecting rise of
iron levels I mean I remember us kind of
getting there pretty fast like maybe on
a Friday maybe maybe wrap the Machine
and all that stuff I'm gonna say rise of
iron dropped on a Tuesday like I don't
normally do and then I believe a rain
was like a Friday I'm pretty confident
that's what it's got about tempting
world's first it's probably I'll make
sense yeah this is kind of the same deal
so I'm thinking a little bigger than
grass machine right around reservoirs
but definitely I don't see I'll be
shocked
you know but I don't think it'll be
forsaken sighs sake was a lot of content
yeah so sorry I just alluded my name's
you know you're good and shout out to
everybody in chat I just got like a
couple more follows up so thank you guys
all for tuned in so welcome welcome glad
to have you guys part of the last worst
right man goodbye to kids fire we got a
lot talk about it's warm in here man
they extended a couple of things about
the dates but we have a road map so we
will jump ahead to that so last week we
got this week at Bungie which dropped
and after all that insanity it was
pretty much just insanity for the full
day or so one of the things how's your
spacesuit wallpaper looking hahahaha yes
good nice
got it a bottle white dwarf it I got
everything else going right my mode
dummy tight nut here at least looks like
he's coming with that space helmet so I
like my hello I like the look on theory
let me shower gotta shut up don't forget
take your nuts coming back you know it
take another comment rolling it fits the
matically you got the whole moon thing
going and what was the property it made
any rocket attracting rocket right yeah
tige nice comeback there's no doubt that
fits perfect with it there's no doubt
but yeah shout out to the warlocks with
the party city level of masks going on
right here what they do to my people man
what they do the country get called out
in a PC video so you can enjoy your
little mask and not be like the
dumb-dumb class of a three come on come
on oh that was well I get it was rough
I've never seen them attack Titans in
that manner it was fun it was needed but
I never seen it blatantly on a
commercial that's funny but this this is
an atrocity do you see this whose man is
it who is what it's like I mean come on
you're a shaman now that's that's that
warlock that's here that's your look you
got that you know this this is party
city ramen there's a shop this is what
this is some put together remember you
get the old mask with the little string
in the back this is that who don't get
started let me guess that we're shout
out to the Titans or not
she's looking real cool in a mall
automatically we got a moment
apparently sell mm-hmm ah but yes so we
got some nice wallpaper so go check them
out if you want them but the big thing
is as with the delay has it got pushed
into October first they did want to
update the calendar for the season of
opulence so we've gotten solstice of
Heroes still through only the 27th so if
you're working on your armor that has
not changed
you can only earn your armor and get it
through the 27th so if you want all
three the grind is still the same time
which I wish they would have changed but
sad they didn't because I it'd be nice
just that more time there's no reason
not to
yeah but they wanted to slap on we've
got another iron banner we've got an
update which we'll talk about in a
second we've got moments of triumph
infamy boost iron banner that mayhem
Valor boost infant boost they're just
like alright lastly extra bonus weeks
just boost boost play crazy all the
stuff flow no that's mostly what that
update what that changed so it was just
like if you're working on you know your
infamy boost you got a couple of those
if you're working on valor boost
everyone's gonna be with you know with
iron banner and then Valor boosts as
well so you look on you're ready let's
see I need that infamous boost bad my
Louis real quickly you know I got gas I
thought I was close to delirium yeah so
I'm like yo so while I'm doing the
solstice grind 410 gambit matches and
all that I looked at much but I'm like
yo I'm getting there and all that's left
is the reset so I got there and it
resets I'm like yeah what's up and I'm
like give me a challenge so my all right
let me research very quick I didn't
realize that to do it again
I don't man so I got you about what my
heart was devastated for 21% delirium
paired by my whole thing seemed I had at
once just once bro I thought that's all
you had to do nope huh I reset it it was
like yeah thanks dude they still dig get
going again and then that's weird
I don't know bro unless it's a glitch
with mine unless I've reset my infamy
and I have not gotten anything and he
has not given me you know
picked the mysterious package it still
says you need to reset it and I went
over at the hover to see if it's like
crucible when you you know press reset
ranking mm-hmm
so when I read online it looks like you
it is a second reset that officially
gives it to you hmm
but weird yeah weird hopefully well you
got some times coming up so that's kind
of the idea moments of triumph you are
looking for those for your shirt for
your MMX iyx titled all those things are
they are coming and you get a little
more time that's through the 17th so
moment so triumph is extended through
the 17th so that's a little bit more
time there but the big thing is the
little patch we got coming on September
3rd moments are extended again so I'm
gonna hit these and then we'll kind of
touch it I'm just gonna say them all
first gambit prime and reckoning weapon
reward rates will be highly increased
reckoning difficulty will be tuned
bright XQ maddox no longer have a daily
lockout mountaintop and Wendigo pinnacle
quest will become more accessible and
then as the season comes to a close
menagerie chess will become more
rewarding as Callas sees fit like
there's a lot to unpack in like five
lines they're just like trying to blow
straight through I'm like hold on pull
it back first
gambit Bremen wreck what reckoning
weapon reward rates try and say that
three times fast but that's a tongue
twister Knapp gambit prime and reckoning
weapon reward rates will be highly
increased they will also have bad luck
protection to guarantee a drop after a
set amount of runs mmm I likes I like
that with reckoning difficulty to be
tuned to be more welcoming as you hunt
for your rewards mm-hmm like I mean yeah
glad we're getting it for shadow key
right about five months too late
let's get very late I was like I mean
that's one of those things people will
grind for but seriously it's kind of
come a little late it let's season the
drifter a little little nudge it's like
Oh black I want the bounties all the
time okay you can have them all the time
oh just mode we created yeah that's
that's a little better now late I'm sure
this is where is like I don't know the
priorities and testing and things like
that
and this is where we'll get into when it
comes a little bit lower
I guess I'll kind of bring it up then
the break schematics for those are who
are going for the wayfarer title this
will help you alive because this sucked
because I got it but it's it's basically
that's the one that's one of the harder
grinds like yeah you have to do
escalation protocol five times to get
your full set but it's these weapons
that you do your daily grind if you got
to get the stims you're gonna create it
you gotta go drive one place and then if
you open it it doesn't have it in there
mmm and you get your weapon of like the
day you can't keep grinding it you can
go get all the stims you want by doing
public events and roles and stuff like
that but you only get one weapon of like
the Mars weapons and I took me like 10
days in a row of doing it for me to get
like the one I needed so it's definitely
a good thing I don't know why it took so
long but I'm glad it's in there too but
yeah this is the big one and this is
kind of a topic for sure I did a whole
video about my father
oh yeah no this is a big you have a lot
of thoughts on this side is you yeah
Windigo gl3 pinnacle quests will become
more accessible specific quest
objectives will be tuned based on player
feedback
oh so that's a thing how much of these
have you done either after that one time
of us running together and I was
watching you and I seen this man did
your dedication to that quest god bless
you like I've seen this man stop what he
was doing break off and chill at the
campfire of the heavy ammo Oh read every
two minutes whatever time it was he
broke camp and he stood right there guys
we're information we're gonna be going
to heavies up excuse me everybody's up
okay everybody everybody work we're
going for point a and point B nevermind
heavies up all we got later see you guys
bro and I sat there and first we'll
shout out to you know in your defense
not just been clowning but like your
whole skill with with
reach to 1-shot joint a plus a plus like
I just don't have that level of patience
and hey if you see but now and this is
where I'll let you go but yeah I've seen
you out there fighting lion and you know
and I'm alright and see me it Jess I'm
such a competitive player my saying I'm
the best deadly average above average
but it just breaks my whole thought
process in my game style from a winning
game style to stop what I'm doing to do
that and I'm just like I know you're
gonna touch it cuz you've made a great
tweet recently I saw your tweet about
this quest and it was fantastic and I
won't steal your thunder with that I'll
let you say that but it's just one of
them things man wait you it doesn't make
you a better but it doesn't show a skill
right in in in in I shouldn't say yeah
that's wrong to me just the play style
needed to get that pinnacle weapon is
not something I consider um you know
some type of behavior that is in the mix
of competitive play it's just something
different you know saying and it goes
against me as a PvP player to try to
play that style you know I'm saying that
especially what is it the last part that
double what is a double kill you got the
devil's new at the medals yeah in the
metal see what I'm saying so it just
like you know III at one point it hurt
my heart cuz I really want this weapon
like I really want this way now there's
an alternative before I even get some
like my thoughts on it you can put play
of the game or something like that a
grenade launcher yeah slowly grind it
out that way right that's literally what
I'm doing I'm doing it in the form of
natural play like again not knocking
anyone who did it the triple grenade set
up whatever whatever not knocking
anybody would reset up it's just it's
more of a page and it's luck of the draw
like come on two guys got to get clumped
up all the time alright then the way
grenade rock it unless you're running a
spike grenade Ryan or you know it's a
lot of variables bro it is tough it is
it could be tough man so salute to you
first of all for doing it like I don't
even know if I'm ever
that yes sir but the question i'ma bring
back to you now that you see this and
you grind it the way they initially
intended right so my question to you is
not as you see this is this this bring
shades of rhetorics remember when reg X
was was acclaimed naturally in the hawk
walk pvp committee was pissed they were
like all even though it's a long quest
you made it easy the world get it like
do you feel it's a mistake for them to
do it like give me your thoughts you are
the owner of the mountaintop know
anybody who goes through this absolutely
will agree that it needs Justin I don't
think there's anybody who made it
through this grind who did it naturally
like you're gonna do with play of the
game who I've heard some people got some
of the work done if they did it
incompetent I comment of that video said
you could do it in lockdown because
that's kind of clumping them up there
are different ways to do it I played it
in iron banner 136 matches of iron
banner God knows it was too many I
counted him I was like alright I'm kind
of curious cuz I played a lot of iron
banner control helps and the grouping
helps but honestly no it needs adjusted
for sure so I mean yeah I went through
it because I was like you know what this
is just gonna try and happen we'll see
how it goes but on the fact that it's
gonna be adjusted should never been that
long I don't care if you hit it or not I
don't think that's a problem
now as halo bear said do you think
reclusive mountain top should get the
rhetorics treatment shadow key hmmm I
think for one if recluse is gonna stay
where it is which I hope it doesn't get
nerfed because it is fun to use I would
like to see them do a variety of that
but the thing I actually and this is
where my whole video went down the
rabbit hole let's go is what this quest
made you do and it's why I kind of
appreciate or a focused week on it it
made you if you really wanted to deep
dive and not just use like a LM use play
the game whenever I get heavy if you
want to go for it you have to learn how
to use breech-loader grenade launchers
you have to absolutely how to use those
but what are you gonna get I'm gonna get
a breach low gradient launcher probably
even more probably even it's even faster
than militias birthright yes so I'm
using 3 yeah it's just crazy fast it's
almost like straight line
in spending my time to grind for these
like I went through the numbers on dim
which I should never have looked but I
did that's good so the grenade launcher
kills you need 750 if you're doing it
normal outside of comm you need 200
double kills 200 double kills that's a
lot so that means you've got to find two
people grouped up you have to kill them
fast enough for the metal to pop up
basically they gotta be like next to
each other in the kill fee and you got
to do them really close together and
then the other pieces you need a hundred
calculated trajectory and it is three
final blows without dying three grenade
launcher final blows without dying so
write down lady trajectory again that it
has to bounce no it doesn't have to
bounce you just have to kill three
enemies with grenade launchers in a
single life in a single life right so
it's like one two and you can get the
third later but you can't dart can be
late at all but you can't die in between
life deals double down triple down no
it's not anything it's just I mean if
you're playing normal it's gonna be
called like double quick and then I
think if you're doing iron banner told
it's something different for a metal but
the general idea is like yeah three kill
streak with the launcher yep okay so
pretty go straight that's fine but and
that's the ID so when I had my final
tally I had a hundred and twenty-five
calculator trajectory cuz I got a little
better with the breach loads and
fighting lion shouts of finding line
guys under appreciated grenade launcher
straight up because it uses primary ammo
so I can actually sit there and shoot
about eight or nine grenades sometimes
get lucky my play style is not honorable
but we'll get to that in a sec and then
the other piece is the fact that
fighting lion uses primary you actually
get a quite you when you pick it up if
you get a me brick I have 19 grenades I
can just shoot them down a hallway for a
long time so get in here three what are
you using to circumvent the single shot
reloaded uh I have two grenade launchers
all your savage you doing switch so
what's the other so wait.you at the top
what do you got you got malicious earth
right yeah see let me put stopped right
there and if you don't that's brown yeah
they have shadows this up right now get
your butt in that nightfall I feel you
bro how many break down how many kinetic
breech launches are they in again oh
there's one aware I'm a person away I'm
not I'm not coming at you this is me
coming that bunch that's a very modest
play style everybody can take advantage
of like I would have had three does your
like PvP crucible I want to win still
let you run three grenade launchers
probably not but at least I'll do a
quick play and be a savage again three
you don't say like it consumed me it's
like could play better even though
they're saying competi gives you a
little bit more you got six people
running around and quick play you know
I'm saying chances are higher of death
you know I'm saying so roll it's
probably your best bet if you're doing
that if you're not doing cookin control
is your if you see a control meant to be
like I control and you switch let's go
out real quick then you go yeah you know
what they gonna be at the campfire be
eating gonna be a campfire a two people
gonna be clumped up completely
completely with you but that's my I was
just like man if I wish I had you know a
birthright or at least they had another
option they went in such trash role to
really oh it's like the worst you could
probably ask
it's like Genesis and by the way which
is just dumb
I'm literally blown up right now cuz
it's so bad but it was it's a journey
but I will say when I got done the title
of the triumph that you need is called
in pursuit of honor I did not feel
honorable I thought I trash I felt
really dishonorable cuz I was as I said
oh we're going to point Pete nevermind I
was like you know a shiny object with
heavy ammo yeah I was behind shooting
grenades baking him around Tony's just
like I was working on pool bank shots
I've got billiard cues out here trying
to Bank I'm around corners like oh good
I mean literally it's like I know people
are in corners I'm like alright Bank
Bank Bank bank oh cool I finally got it
I'm like I'm just shooting just BS
around corners now the fun ones are it's
like okay so a shoot fighting line but I
don't get there and fighting line won't
one shot but I get him low and then my
militias birthright had a pretty high
velocity so it was like new and the one
behind it would be like and I could like
DoubleTap them pretty quick and that's
not
in the noodling there were times that
would get double kills with those two
grenade launchers because two people on
points I'd actually tagged them close
enough and quick enough it was a rare
but actually using the three worked as a
benefit to me because rarely I would
actually get the double or the single
sup question what mod did you put
putting onto the the slinger like a free
hand grip or something like that okay
yeah yeah free hand no I've got snap
shot sites and Genesis you're not gonna
use either of those you're not gonna
look at sight of the grenade launcher
and then Genet no it's just yeah you had
the two worst possible yeah yeah but get
a shout out to having to go kinetic in
the entire game one that you're trying
to acquire John a bunch of for that yeah
yeah the one the one that you want would
make the quest even better so but no the
quest is too long I ended up with thirty
seven hundred grenade launcher kills two
hundred of the multi kills so I had that
exactly that was my last 125 of the
calculator trajectory so like the number
of grenade kills I got far exceeded by
5x the other two by huge margins so like
those who probably could be cut in half
and it'd be better like multi kills
could be tuned a little better some
tweaks definitely for sure so am i okay
with this getting tweaked yes do I think
I would like to see and that's what I
was gonna get back to recluse recluse
really all you have to do if I remember
correctly you just have to get fabled
period right that's it yeah
now this is one where I was like I'd
like to see honestly I like how revoke
her you got to get sniper headshots and
you got to get sniper kills and I would
like to if they're gonna do a tweak to
the recluse quest or bring it in make
you learn submachine guns make you equip
them make you get types of kills make
you get like maybe a double kill or then
I mean you'll see like risk runners and
Huckleberry's and exactly I'm all about
that ya know I was gonna say I just like
the idea of a quest teaching you to use
the style of gun but you're about to
earn that's the best part of it right
again that if the the mindset is correct
right you want to get this this dope
weapon you have to use this style of
weapon that you normally don't you
that's what what's the bungees good at
it's just the third part of it the
calculated trajectory the length of it
killed it was just a bit excessive and
you know I think that's where they kind
of dropped the ball they know it because
clearly it's being mentioned now based
on your feedback you know kind of thing
and we'll see out it I'm just curious e
how extensive the nerf goes to the quest
yeah and oh for the record I'm waiting
I'm not I'm not even know no I haven't
young Windigo yet I'm not touching it
until it changes so yeah yeah oh wait X
yeah yeah and then we got the menagerie
chest getting more rewarding as galaxy's
fit think this is them listening to
enough people like griping and moaning
and groaning saying alright I think we
did a little little too far yeah not the
case my boy
you threw out a nice video I did so many
people were like not most people were
not happy and then the problem was it
was such a good grind that the people
used it so much when you made it such a
bad grind yeah the people were like is
my time worth going back in there and
even on my own to work on some random
stuff occasionally definitely less so so
then the people playing in are
blueberries and the people who are
experienced it experienced it it's much
slower than it already was so they were
really good fast efficient runs or at
least if half a team was like knew what
they were doing you're playing with like
hey those three know what the hell
they're doing I got paired up with your
group that group is not playing this
anymore because they put their time in
and they're done so you have a whole lot
less skilled players in an activity
there's now a lot less rewarding and the
other thing is I have more gyms than
I'll ever be able to spend it's the five
or six chest pools like if you did it if
you did one menagerie in five or
successful switch you know people could
do a hundred pools and still not get the
gun they want because right
that's just RNG mmm with all the gyms
that you earn and you have these little
buffs and you pick them up in all these
different places right
I'm never gonna spend enough of them and
that's just kind of an imbalance in yeah
incarceration so let me ask you this how
to use how do you think they handle
callous sees fit I don't think it's
gonna be enough personally I've heard
some people say like three would be
great just stick three just that they
gonna be like hey and you have like 180
seconds so you can sit there and be like
alright so I want these in here pull one
okay and you don't have to run back and
forth that's just dumb but I like also
some of the ideas maybe it's
you and if you unnormal say you finish
one like you hit the full half bar
completion of one event like in there
and you get a bonus chest
I like those ideas where it's like
rewarding skilled playthroughs making it
more valuable heroic that's a whole
different thing you need like a Chester
than that insanity but yeah generally I
would like to see mm-hmm two to three I
mean three would be awesome and then a
bonus a chain store and more it would be
like the dream I think that's what three
is somewhere in the number that people
think it's like okay three poles is
starting to look reasonable mm-hmm
agrees me sidenote
you're some you said side note and then
I lost you oh yes I'd no I say your
services for us some night falls I have
the the the majestic armor for the
solstice oh yeah that 200 oh yeah we're
gonna need another we're gonna need
another one player to play a shadow
grown and all I'm putting you to work
early I'm putting I'm putting in my
request literally okay and truth true
told me that I gotta call you for the
three night falls and 100 song
a case I think some like that so I'm
like truth wants something with three
night anytime I see nightfall I'm like
I'm leavin equity that's for II and I
see him late night fall I've got videos
for him bad that we got we I take the
man we gotta get the man that pretty
much wraps up last week guys so
definitely cool stuff shout-out to Cosmo
welcoming a new life into the world with
he and his wife so salute yeah so
awesome that they baby mechanic came
three weeks early but put at nine pound
sounds like this Titan was ready to
break out so yeah we had definitely the
Community Managers are out and I don't
know if you guys follow deeds but he had
so much fun this week on Twitter yeah
like he's like alright we have 19 new
rules now you must be streaming if you
were a streamer you must be in a suit
and formal attire
I saw glad was actually in a suit on one
of his streams I was just laughing yeah
he's been having way too much fun this
week but yeah that's most of the
previous week so we're kind of caught up
we know about what's going on with we
never raid the delay and everything like
that and then on top of a delay Luke
Smith said that he's like hey I'm
working on a state of the game kind of
one so what he's learned over the last
six months and a couple things and then
he put out a recent tweets basically
yesterday saying well about 40 40 100
words so far for part one but eight
pages single-spaced and part two is
still under construction and then even
said was like hey anybody got any
recommendations for dictation software
so you know we're we're gonna have a lot
to read which and it's gonna be early
next week and I'm like early next week
because he was hoping this week but it
didn't quite happen cuz that's a lot
well yeah we're gonna get a large
substantial like eight page stay to the
game
deep dive into honestly what the end
they rephrase it as looking at the last
six months of learnings from destiny to
and outlining the kind of changes were
making to the game and shadow keep and
why like oh that type of developer game
director level insight is I can't wait
to just like pick anything apart know
that as a gamer that kind of stuff
excites me you know I love this you just
go behind the curtain right just to see
what their thought process is to see how
they envision what we've been going
through and Luke is the main like listen
man it's that's the man who could do you
could do no wrong in my eyes man I still
say one of the most gangsters moves is
while employed under Activision tellin
Activision who previously dissed them on
an earnings call we liked our game oh we
like talking so you're not gonna do that
like that's balls that's like your boss
boss that's the corporate suits telling
you something and you fire back things
worse things have happened so Luke
that's the man like him and shot the
mark knows worthy to ask my guy know Sam
but Luke will always and then he has the
greatest um are heading for his twitter
account so it references there are only
just a greatest rate of all time and
yeah yeah that's the greatest line next
to next that was it came from the moon
but your audience make their own fate is
the greatest destiny line I'm telling
you right that's the Proverbs a
scripture y'all
salut I love that it preach the word
today
oh yeah so that'll be coming early next
week and I'm gonna we're gonna have a
lot to talk about with that one and for
those of you guys who are in here now
I'll say it again at the end but we do
have a special guest lined up next week
to talk about all this stuff we're about
to talk about we're gonna we're gonna
have so much to talk about between
Luke's deep dive we've got a stream
coming up we'll talk about in a minute
and whatever else is coming on the table
so Friday morning on the 16th we've got
Paul Tassie coming to join just right
there what if you listen you got that
early scope if you like I thought we was
gonna miss the Reeboks tomorrow a today
oh if you're listening right now you get
the treat by sticking your in the middle
you're in the middle of the podcast you
get a treat right now so next week
hi I'll say it at the end I'll put maybe
a little breakfast in there so but no
yeah huge fan
we already know who man is and it's
gonna be great we couldn't pick a
perfect week so much is gonna be
dropping as we talked about okay it's
gonna be it's gonna be late thanks lil
at the campfire is going to be crazy
next Friday but I cannot waver yeah I
mean he's always got good articles like
I mean we met up at Guardian Con and
he's honestly ultra nice guy very happy
about just like just people being
receptive and things like that with
regards to like his articles be like oh
it's like and people that caught so
click maybe it's like no he's he's might
do an article to get you in but it's
like if you read that article it's
always so like it's a fair perspective
every time he's gonna bash it if it's
not good he's gonna raise it if it's
good like he's he's a fair guy well I
appreciate that so it's what you said
because I literally told him that to his
face there's been times where he's had
an article title and it triggered me but
then I took my emotion on just read cuz
sometimes you know you get caught up
with a title
and you get in there and you like you
know well yeah he's right you know I'm
saying that's that's the cool part man
so uh yeah stay tuned there's gonna be
us
nice nice ride man it's gonna be late
yeah be a little later next week so
we'll probably start a little later
yeah can accommodate his schedule and
stuff but it should still be in the
morning so looking forward to that one
for sure it'll be freaking awesome but
yeah we got more info this week drop in
first one is our little trailer about
destiny 2 on Steam so you will be able
to link your account you're not gonna be
able to play yet everybody's like I'm
going in to play over there no the the
actual just linking of the accounts for
now to make sure like one stock Annie
the other when you will not be able to
play cross save comes later mm-hmm
unless I'm reading that wrong but it's
destiny to want PC we'll be moving to
our new home on Steam in with the
announcement from last week about our
new launch window and that's what they
said like it'll shadow keep will lot
like steam will launch with shadow keep
like notice I think go together but it
says destiny two will arrive on Steam
for the first time on October 1st
there's the line I was looking for okay
you're not gonna play before but before
that happens on August 20th you'll be
invited to link your characters and then
cross save is the next day so like we're
getting across save and all this stuff
done now
so dude this is the best part of the
play this is the best part of the shed I
literally like oh yeah a two-week
crossfades moving up bingo ding ding
ding ding ding ding and today I'll be
shout out tool I got an article out
there please guys show some support
Lords of gaming that net oh my put it
out there break it now because it is a
little confusing for those who you know
not knowing what's going on on a PC side
because the PC move there's a little
intricate parts but kind of what you
said and it's like again not cross play
cross save but what they're doing is
they give me that window on the 20th to
say okay link your account to from your
your battlenet to your um what you call
it's your steam now here's the thing on
I put this in articles a lot of people
may not realize as I put it in bold bro
guys you have until October first to get
that done after October 1st if you do
not make that decision you do not get
the catch a chance to bring that
character over ever
again so it's almost like a cutoff date
hard and fast so get it done on the 20th
hopefully you're not out of town for two
weeks so whatever whatever I mean you
get like six weeks true get it done just
I'm just a straggler Zoar people cuz I
don't procrastinate exactly you a
battlenet it will be no more destiny
over there you will not be able to do it
so that's the key that I saw okay they
got a highlight that but um yeah man
this is this is exciting now already and
then today they said you know can you in
their Q&A a little fact thing you know
can you pre-order now cuz I I held off I
said let me just wait but you know
formation but then today they officially
said no you can pre-order shadow key on
steam now and be okay so I did that part
and then xx I'll link and then I'll be
good to go so they got they got my money
today coming as well so across say from
people coming from console who may be
content creators I mean there's the cool
guys the follow-ups and stuff they make
videos they have a computer to do that
especially cool guy he's got a really
nice computer now helped him with that
thanks to someone I know hey I look I
was like I was I was I enjoy those
things so happy to help him with that
one and YouTube so but it is funny
actually looking at his comments and
videos he's saying hey I got this loose
PC and the specs and stuff like that and
there are a lot of comments on his
videos that are talking about oh we lost
another one to PC and nobody's gonna be
playing on console anymore and like a
lot of people because the substantial
piece of the population is no on console
so what content creators I mean you got
the dados you got a lot of us play on PC
because you make the content you have a
good PC and it's nice to play on there
and things are different look I've made
a very very very avid point of saying
laying I'm the only one of my friends
that he's specifically plays with he's
like yeah I'll jump on it's like play on
PC with you Bond has playing ps4 fallout
like stuff like that but he was like he
was very evidence to end plague there
were people who were just like upset in
his comments that he was gonna leave
Xbox really oh yeah just about this oh I
know about this continue
I don't know about all this buddy I mean
that people are just like Oh most a lot
of the content creators are on PC and
it's like that console perspective is
appreciated and that's one thing he said
he's still gonna make sure he sticks
with a lot of because most of his
friends are still there he's like I'll
play other places and so he's like if my
other seven friends buy pcs like next
week yeah I'll probably play PC more
because like I have seven people that I
like those are my crew playing with them
for like five years so gonna be on Xbox
a lot but if he's like I want to make
that one like hey let me pissed off in a
couple places that's cool but it was
just interesting to see the like like
the upheaval in the other or over like
the Leo console to my dude I got
harassed I got dizzy all these got
traitor this not all jokes aside like it
does hurt because the thing is as a
console main initially right dude I got
pretty large clan you know shoutout to
sinister shot the addict I mean we were
raiding distant huge huge these guys got
just tons of funds in memory so when I
did the switch I got bro there was the
nastiness man it was all man he's that
said we're never gonna see him again
he's over and the sad thing is because
there was no cross save you gotta be
realistic like how much was that gonna
be going back and forth with two
different characters in crying I mean
it's just too much so with this now and
I told mine they don't believe me right
now but in saying this one last word for
the first time well I told us look I am
going to be raiding more and doing more
cooperative activities on console
because like I like my solo grind here
and I like getting the difficult night
for soloist shadow thrown guy you know
and I need to get it's good to have a
resource like he bought his car let's
just say you know so that's here and not
shout to stone stone facade to scream so
many fun cool people to play with don't
get me wrong but I got a tribe of people
that are content of just all the time
all the time all the time so it's like
case in point I haven't even done crown
of Sorrows yeah man hurts my heart
I haven't even done it so it's like
again I think the way I'm gonna handle
it personally is a lot of my solo play
you know
meaning I work on my PC a lot absolutely
but the cool thing is when I want to
read or I might even do this it's gonna
sound crazy I'm actually gonna buy three
copies and shadow keep I'm buying a
PlayStation 4 one and I buy an xbox one
because because you're an xbox career I
gotta shout to Josh reading I got a
whole subset of PlayStation guys that
have never played with yeah never you
know so they just like y'all will be and
it's out to UM Rev plays you know it's
it's gonna be I'm investing that money
that's how much this feature is
important I know so many desti got and
the worst thing that happens you start
talking destiny with it someone for the
first time you know what what console
you got and you're like ah oh yeah it
did it just breaks things down you're
never gonna play it again yeah we can
literally do it now dude I'm buying
three copies I know it's gonna sound
crazy but I move around however I see
fit
that's how I'm doing but that's one
thing we've all said so much is the fact
that like if we had cross saved people
would buy multiple copies for like bacon
what is it a 180
well it's 120 but what I think it like
the annual pass it'll probably be 180
what you probably will also you know I'm
getting it get it all all all the places
but I mean that's kind of one of those
things people have said now we know all
that money like if I buy three copies
still go on a bungee so it's going to
police thirsty no but I'm so high oh no
I mean I think it's gonna be really cool
for me as I've been on mouse and
keyboard so much like I'll play God of
War I'll play certain games actually
feel really good on controller and this
is my no it's hard for me to like when I
played a shooter as much as I have on
console like I'll go pick up like sec
hero Dark Souls blood-borne cata more
adventure game Zelda whatever with a
controller and that feels right it does
but for me as I play as I played more
and more shooters on PC for back two
years now it's just heart I'm gonna be
terrible with a controller that's all
use console shaving y'all get them get
it early I literally put myself down
come on get up combat boys you see if
your console is shaming you I got it
literally did not say that oh I know but
I got it though so I gotta make you see
myself but I did what he said oh but I
did not come out from the heavens to
play with you if you if I'm like yeah
obey all you want to jump on ps4 and
help me in whisper I would be trash I'm
pretty sure I would be you gotta give
back to the community you gotta go back
to you who you gotta go back to the
ghetto sometimes and play with your
humble beginnings plug in a controller
here oh no Missy and see if I suck there
so but yes it is a very cool thing for
nearly everybody and especially just for
those who want to have the option I
think it's really cool so cross say it
was gonna be huge
PC going to steam new lights gonna be
just boosting that population I think
new light is gonna be nice for ps4 and
Xbox but new light on Steam it's gonna
be just bonkers huge I think because
steam is massive and you put that level
of a free game there are very few free
games at the level of like destiny to
with its current state of like you're
one but also like the fixes and stuff so
listen I'm telling you right now first
of all I got to come and see the caverns
killer yes I got I got a call it that
said Fred but but uh listen man people
don't understand it shout out to the
Borderlands people all three of you in
here I'm just joking
shout out to slow more that's my god I
like teaser but um no all jokes aside
again people are saying all their
scaring whatever whatever I tell him I'm
telling people again cross save a new
light alone forget any errors content
forget any shadow key if it have any
excuse me DLC and they just made those
announcements boil and still in trouble
that that's how much requested this is
these are huge
now the other time I gotta make is shout
out to all the events on a tango show
that's not gonna be made heroic with all
these blueberries coming through cuz you
know what's happening he you know not
knowing how to do these public blueberry
invasion is happening get ready
it's that's like their needs I'm gonna
me and probably many other people I need
to try and put together a new player
series about what do as a new player are
you a blueberry do you know what a
heroic event public event is nope you're
a blueberry all right listen up I mean
I'm the perfect video right there bro
I'm serious no there's gonna be there's
gonna be mini I mean I just I almost
want to start a nuke
I know it sounds stupid but I want to
like either have my wife play which i
think would be amazing but I'll never
get her to do it but just have somebody
who hasn't played destiny like tell me
the things a new player needs to know
because somebody's like well what are
these little green blinking lights on
the ground our patrols are they
worthwhile no motive it's like what our
powerful gear like what's the way to do
these things and it's like I still think
they briefly said when you start a new
light trying to remember what they said
I think they're almost gonna start like
750 when they come in light so you're
gonna be fairly high they don't have to
go through because some people somebody
was asking me on Twitter like okay I
haven't played destiny in a long time
how do I start this thing it was like go
try and do the the quest on the barge so
you get your 690 gear but unfortunately
some people are like you need to do the
Forsaken campaign before you can do that
so trying to understand those pieces
while also explaining hey what are
ascended challenges what the hell's in
the Dreaming city you know how do you do
a rate how do you find people or the
Blake there's a lot for that this game
when you look at the director has so
much going on laying I think it's nice
with new life that they are gonna like
slowly ease these people and I think
that's actually a really good strategy
because when you look in the whole thing
I'm like okay new person they're like
what do I do and yes that's a smart way
they're gonna kind of ease them in which
will be good so mm-hm
absolutely they got they have to ease
and a yeah we got we got to see you know
how to handle as far as that like I
think it's gonna be a situation like
forsaken where you know you're gonna
have to beat that to be able to access
the same thing with shadow key but you
know as they move forward I think we're
just subsequent season passes you have
to be shadow keep before you can you
know fully invest you can go to the play
space you can go to the area you can
patrols but as far as like that hardcore
in-game content up
each annual pass section I don't think
they'll be able to access that you know
it'll be a la carte you know hey you
want to do this okay pick it up yeah I
mean right now honestly if you picked up
destiny there's different collections
for it but they ain't like if I mean I
have these to do a giveaway for I
literally have the legendary collection
ps4 and 2 for PC then I got to do a
video for I haven't lost the giveaway
but the annual pass is $15 whole damn
thing so if you get like if you can get
your hands on like the Forsaken
legendary collection plus the annual
pass like I'm gonna try and hook people
up so but that's like there's so much
content between those you add shadow
keep on top of it I still want the
answers of like Armour 2.0 is it gonna
go in effect for all the old armor like
yeah are these people who come jump in
with new light and they go play on Titan
is their armor gonna look like armor 2.0
is it gonna like old trash like that is
the that lot of coral many questions to
answer and speaking of that setting
segue their segue so we got the kind of
roadmap for all of what we get to look
forward to in the next coming weeks and
streams and reveals and all of those
types of things so we know director's
cut quotas what they called it from Luke
Smith basically part 1 is gonna be
coming early next week and that's really
cool looking forward to reading that 8
page dissertation over the history
destiny so much to get from there cuz
it's gonna be what have they learned
what are they put into shadow keep why
are they doing that RPG is like if he
just goes to town I will be just reading
it like a book you know yeah that's
number one so and that's and the number
two like they did put out at like 8
tweet saying hey what would you like to
see and I was like Armour 2.0 was in if
not in the list it was in almost
everybody's things so number 2 armor
customization preview livestream that is
on Wednesday that is quick and I cannot
wait how hype are you I'm gonna like
jump out of my chair through my ceiling
right now cuz I'm worried for you man
dude this is this is my stuff this is
what
I got a new just just keep it we saw
moosa' who said I'm worried that they
mate they may do it knocking out the
part to the levels you want I don't ah
so okay I will say I don't think it's
gonna be all the way to levels I want
that's what Isaac I think what you want
ultimately will be d3 but I think this
will be the progression right this will
be that next part so I just want you to
get in expectation I just want answers
because like if I make a video about
like new light for players I want to be
able to tell them how armor works cuz
that's half of your damn arm stuff that
you have so I was like this is big for
me because I can at least sit there and
be like okay at least I think I
understand how this is gonna work so I
can make a video and schedule it get
ready like right now I feel like I'm
talking just like hey here's the summary
you pick it up you're gonna have well I
have no idea if this is gonna even make
sense so this being the first thing and
one of the biggest things is really nice
they're not saving it for like the tail
in because I would have killed him for
that but yeah so number three more
shadow key details at Gamescom
tom is huge so they're going to
Germany's in Cologne and definitely Show
Me State which means they have a lot to
show yep number when is games gone by
the way oh that's good question soon
dates off top I'm googling it real quick
it's in 11 days okay so a--the know and
then in order they have cross they've
launched which is the 21st xx xx for
21st of 21st a process xx is one you can
link yep 21st so definitely get some
more information the week after so we
get this coming week and then you have
the next week we have some information
number 5 is how seasons will change in
destiny to year 3 that sounds familiar
almost verbatim from the PAP attended at
weird weird your baby PvP reveal
foreshadow keep this is where you've got
to keep your expectations in check man
yeah I wrote again
Lord's Day Lords of gaming that net
please check out got a couple paragraphs
in the after the table about my thoughts
and yeah man this child Arrakis man he
had one of the greatest responses
forearmed each and he just said um you
know what do you guys mean as far as pvp
is going to change you know I'm saying
like what does that mean that statement
and I'm shocked
I'll be honest like is it probably only
trials most likely not but the fact that
it's being addressed they have a bullet
point for this and then seven will be an
invitation to the crucible at PAX it's a
play this is another reveal this is
interesting I got a little excited
because I'm like okay PEP reveal cool
molds new change is fine but then you're
inciting people they have a mood to show
no what do you guys cuz that's you're
gonna get me hope why would you have an
invitation to the crucible at PAX unless
there is something one if you play
elimination but it's not trials as long
as this backdrop as long as this better
bring it back just get that motive you
know Sam but I do feel something's
cooking now because normally expectation
very low then doing meta balanced Maps
that's how I'm thinking I met a balanced
Maps you'd be okay you were inviting
people on pax
you got a mole bro I'm you got a mole
something we see is is back or some new
mode that you want to debut cuz they
love to say that you know Charles the
old ways not the way so maybe they got
something new something new what hot
watch it beyond riff I'd like to see
rift back actually on top of what you
said but I would like to see rift back
at some point mm-hmm so that's a lot
aussie freed he's evil you really what
he's doing to be right we've decided
actively help out our pvp community two
new maps will be introduced every the
reverence plane was going on brother
season
see so yeah that's a lot of stuff so
director's cut armor customization more
shadow keep details which there's one
thing is I've made a video about it
yesterday
yeah there's no specific place when you
look at that I still when you go to
Bungie store and I want to buy the games
I wanna buy like the releases for like
shadow keep it doesn't say anywhere when
you look at the stuff that you get new
missions do you quest the intestine
nations new dungeon new armor new raid
season pass no strikes
oh this is in a collector's edition no
it's just standard edition it doesn't
say they usually put new strikes new
crucible Maps that's not listed as a
bullet point on pre-ordering shadow keep
all right now keep talking I just have
to assume that they have two that
they're gonna be in there don't you
think what are you seeing the bullet
points of them listen I'm seeing bullet
points so if you go to bungie.net you
hit and look at destiny to click on
shadow keep scroll down and see
pre-order and just like the shadow keep
standard edition bullet points with her
logos next to it say new missions and
quests we know we're gonna have a
campaign for sure new exotic quests ton
of things new destination the moon new
dungeon probably on the moon we know the
new raid is gonna be in the black garden
new armor and gear turn cool season pass
for season of the undying
although yeah it doesn't mention strikes
doesn't mention crucible Maps doesn't
mention game the maps doesn't mention
any of that type of stuff not listed and
more and that's some of its hopefully
assumed but that's one thing I actually
had a curiosity because I mean we could
go two ways with this right we go
fourteen strikes right now mmm-hmm if we
do you think we get any and if we get
any how many do you think we get we've
got to get strikes just off the strength
of its a new you know campaign in shadow
area how many do you think we get oh the
cops coming battle we're breaking down
in a second
all right cool for me my assumption I'll
throw it out there first because I was
wondering I'm guessing because with
forsaken we ended up getting three so as
this is kind of rise of iron size not
crazy big my assumptions about three
what do you think two or three two or
three um we've gotta get strikes I think
I'm not gonna go crazy with this
pre-order list yet because I think
marketing strategically does not want to
reveal their hand yet on everything that
is included in this DLC this expansion
once we get closer once we get you know
past you know as you get closer doctor
October first like that week or two when
they like okay cross saves out everybody
get your pre-orders is coming it's
driving next week that list that we'll
see on a PlayStation Store or on an Xbox
store I think will be updated and we'll
have I cannot see them not doing strikes
in this case I can't this would be I
just can't see how I listen is saying
it's not there but I cannot see that
happen a mess can show said it right we
for sure get the ps4 exclusive strike to
PC forget about that is we get one at a
minimum for us other players besides me
or we get that exclusive now and we get
wave splitter what what wave butter no
trace this is kind of powerful right now
faces some traces in then PvP yeah
traces of coaster on them yeah I've been
melted by a couple oh shout out to the
Prometheus lens emblem that's how I've
been feeling I get it but that's a great
angle by the way it's almost a little
bright on my screen when I put on like a
little bunch but it is amazing so it's
great
oh yeah the Mod Squad as many of you
have asked us to elaborate as what we
refer to his armor 2.0 next week we'll
do just that
so on the 14th 10 a.m. Pacific they will
do a live stream on Twitch YouTube and
mixer and somebody even was like hey how
about Facebook gaming and they're like
we'll work on that
haha I'm a customization preview
livestream or building a better monster
killing machine whatever II want to call
it mm-hmm and they have a little gift
rolling through all these little mod
choice options some of them are
recognizable with like reserves and
unflinching and target acquisition some
of them I don't recognize at all cuz I
just I slowed this thing down broke down
the frames and look I'm have I con is
that are different some have different
background like there's these little
triple down arrows behind them those are
new they're these little skull looking
things with stuff in the middle
so I don't know how much I'm really
wondering if we get what like trying to
save my words I'm wondering if they're
just gonna kind of like rework how armor
is and that's what I literally said
recently and kind of like if I think the
Solstice armor is worth it and we
haven't actually done what solstice
we'll get to that but mostly if it's
gonna my assumption or at least though
it was kind of described is going to be
like is this like a spacesuit skin that
I think might pick my perks that I put
into I mean that's what at least it
seemed to be and forget is what they
kind of alluded right when Luke Smith
was a swab or two ago yeah you know he
mentioned about hey if I liked hand
cannons and I want to put two different
type of hand cannon moms and then you
know mods inside and then kind of
unlocking as things go on as well so I
got kind of like a d1 nodes vibe
combined with a cut with a combination
of some type of choice with armor mods
so that's the initial vibe I got looking
at this image yeah there's definitely
some things in it I don't what these
icons represent you know I mean so you
know it'll be interesting I mean again
gonna keep it in check armor has always
been the Achilles heel you know weapons
get tremendous love and rightfully so
they get tweaks they get tombs they get
catalysts you know armor has been
lagging behind for much much long time
it needs to shine it needs to shine so
um and then like you said the questions
what happens like all the old stuff like
will
maybe new versions of the stuff you know
is the old stuff most likely gonna be
obsolete you know that's another thing
you know it is it's a lot of questions
going forward I have a feeling the old
stuffs gonna be obsolete I have the
strong today there are no tourists for
that I'm you know what I'm thinking
because you know when I go to on the EDC
right and you go to govern and you're
cashing in your tokens for Russell Varon
listeners but on wash it down slowly
apartment you know there's farming so
all and you still get in his loop a pool
those old primaries they didn't have
random roles dude a half of the
nightfall strikes or that way the
nightfall game this is something I
talked about with my strikes video was
like nightfall exclusives are all mean
you go get oh let me run Sabbath oon
song as nightfall why why I read it I'm
gonna get the duty-bound auto rifle that
has old perks on it and the other piece
is like strike exclusives used to be or
like radix some of that stuff used to be
cool like if I'm gonna go into a strike
where void crystals represents like dead
Guardians and they're using the void to
like power this thing give me an auto
rifle fine if it's an auto rifles an
auto rifle but give me like something on
that that looks like it's ripped out of
the hive Shriekers lash oh oh
angry and it's like a void auto rifle
because that's the idea behind that
whole thing like you're wasting like
that
yeah sorry contain no no just those
things they give me stuff like that go
ahead yeah I would you just you brought
back old feels I remember do the dark
blade yes the darkling helm and you get
the diffusion and look like it came from
it lake bring new the shield brothers
like arms the gauntlet stood on my Titan
Oh remember to fall in the saber strike
I used to get that war mother hell with
electricity and the day has the coolest
I'm a beaver what you eat that's why I
don't do night falls no more me like
knife Falls to me I mean they're
available your button that's all they
are that's it yeah it's like it it's in
this weird place where I don't feel
they've ever recaptured the magic
of the d1 knife you know I'm saying the
d1 nightfall to me I think still with
the customization is a little too wonky
I don't want to yeah I gotta go get a
card from this and I got to do this and
it's just like honestly I don't do them
I do not do them and then when I see the
drop rates and I and I see you guys you
know really killing it out there and I'm
like for these old role weapons I what
let you know remember what was the
weapon that was the better better Devils
it was a hand cannon it was um all shout
to scream with the maillot helmet you're
the one room would but right the UM stay
with that hand cannon that started at
the launch of d2 just before random
rolls better dome no no it was a better
better devil it was a hand cannon that
is I've got what strike it's it's
associated with but it's a better
version of it and I'm like I'm not
grinding for that it's not know random
rolls on no the DFA that hole that DFA
dangling thank you that was that was
Osiris yeah it's like big big chat what
led you here DFA I'm like why am I going
to grind for DFA card what incentive do
I have for that I mean it's got a decent
perk pool but there's stuff that blows
their way anymore lately there's no
random rolls on it so there's no repeat
- going back for it shout out to my
curated roll Kindle or get my god you
got the ring control on that hland Oh
kill clip and rampage on a hand can I do
is gonna be blowing people away mail and
it's easel it bow is silky oh but in PvE
I am Toba PvP it no baby here's where
the healing
Oh bro you know disgusting it is to get
rampage times three and reload and still
have that and kill clip with a rampage
back going but it's a disgusting yeah
crazy oh no you know I saw that and I
was like woo you've got to come believe
it yeah I couldn't believe hmm yeah man
they got me they gotta fix this hole
they gotta bring they're sitting on so
much old content that can easily just
bring I should say easily
because we don't know what it takes to
get that done but one would see like hey
if you're struggling to make stuff you
got a whole pool of resources that you
can bring forward let's do it man and
vendor refreshes come on let's go
faction rally let's go come on
I need it I mean for me that's what I've
actually been kind of thinking about for
videos lately it's like stuff to talk
about and for me it was like strikes
it's a big one because that's one thing
I do a lot of but how can you take
strikes we had skeleton keys before yep
it was like you had you could get strike
exclusives that were truly for like that
strike in the nightfall but we don't
have we have strike exclusive we have
ships we have transmat effects we have
ghost shells we have snare oohs all of
those are cosmetic things if those exist
in a strike for a drop those should be
like hey you can get this and a piece of
armor and a weapon like you should be
able to get a whole thing what if I go
into Lake of shadows and I beat the boss
and the strike exclusive is a chest arm
and that gives me 5% resilience and
extra damage against taken like people
are like well what if that makes you
more powerful in the Dreaming City rate
then it makes you more powerful in the
drinkie city rage like I want to go into
a place get an exclusive piece of
something and have it be cool because it
makes me more powerful other places like
that bonuses in reckoning hurt my head
so bad because it's not it's so so
focused down to a point of just game to
prime it hurts yeah no you look you know
the thing about this whole thing that
it's just that they are sitting on old
d1 ideas that if they just if it was if
it was as easy as pushing a button oh
well yeah bro it would be it would be so
late because I just missed that I missed
what you just said I miss having those
three options you should be like three
or four options you can grind for eat
grinding nose knife for all rewarding
you know I'm a shout out to a mission
and he won't remember the dust by dust
Palace cloaks yes yes throw like it
moves it was so cool
to see and I liked it too drought rates
were low but again like you said let's
get the skeleton keys back right so that
if there's something you really want you
know so you really want to ground for it
give that make sure I'll show the drop
raise a little low but you go in there
and then you get that guaranteed you and
I'm saying you're gonna get one of those
things just they just need it man it is
sitting on stuff they said I hope with
shadow keep at least we get some of it
you know I'm saying surely it was take
like the normal Vanguard strike playlist
and then maybe there's a heroic strike
playlist which I don't know why they got
rid of that cuz regular strikes are not
hard yeah I know you've got your night
flow you've got your difficulties in
there but say your strike playlist lets
you earn key fragments mm-hmm then for
like five strike runs you get you can
make it into a full key mmm and then you
can either open the chest there maybe if
you do at nightfall it's one straight up
key right there and you can open it
maybe you do the hundred thousand it's
worth two keys because you broke broke
through the barrier like give us reasons
in this entire Vanguard thing like story
missions what the hell who when's the
last time anybody in chat ran those
three story missions were powerful I
can't even be level in a character and
I'm not even gonna do it I'm never doing
that they they should be incorporated
some other way it just that it's not a
good way and let can we give I Cora
something to she's over there twiddling
our thumbs man can we give our girl
something to do the other chick what's
the owner old she'll blow your head off
man I'm sorry what's her name the queen
is here let's go to clean oh no Sparrow
Sparrow woman
why am I forgetting all the name right
now Holly can we give her something Joe
she's the case don't just like oh you
have the text Mechanica shepper inquest
cool i'll see you next year it is just
it is so many cool ideas and you just
wonder you just wish that they just
again can unleash me and even if it's
bits and pieces we gotta get something
you gotta get one of those do you
whether it's old armor coming back
vendor refreshes faction rally
night for rewards with you know those
skeleton keys or something
please bunch we gotta get those back
add is so much incentive to heart yeah
it'd be just a way to like give life
back into something that for most people
they don't touch I mean you go through
and this is kind of gonna bring us to I
guess like the final piece cuz we've got
I mean we know mods are coming yaysies
been a thing we've got changes coming to
the AZ grind and that's kind of where I
want to I guess get us to but it's they
want you to go play strikes they're
gonna force you to go play strikes cuz
nobody wants to give us a reason cuz if
you look in your triumphs so you've got
play 25 strikes in a season okay why why
if I have like exclusive gear to go for
exclusive armor like random perks that
can drop in there what if those things
can drop with like mods what if you know
there are all those things that go for
and there's not like oh I'm gonna go
play the arms dealer and get the tilt
view Sparrow like who gives a look like
who cares it's true you don't I'm
worried about to the raid that like the
older Leviathan raids like yes
just gonna be using the only they've got
to figure out armor 2.0 is gonna have
some tough questions that has to be
answered that the Red Queen knows
already
but um in the scenes behind the scenes
like we have to find out like what how
are they gonna handle it cuz I think it
won't disappoint some if it's just
completely clean break and nothing gets
updated it's on floor yeah I don't need
my old stuff to get like my vault to
change in the armor 2.0 but if it's like
hey I can go earn stuff and there's a
reason it has different like if I can go
earn stuff even if it is older stuff but
I can still learn an armor 2.0 version
of it that I'm okay with like every a
lot of people have the tendency to want
to be like oh well I spent this entire
year holding on to stuff if you play any
other game besides this when you make a
new jump to the next expansion
everything you've got you Minister just
throw in the trash because you're
useless
like it's not come up or be in feud like
the fact that we and you still kind of
blows me away
yeah if this is their way of saying eh
take everything you got throw all the
just clean off that desk and put in the
trash I mean for me it would be a
godsend cuz I could clear up my vault
yesthank guy you hoarder
please let me clear that clean your
house but I'm holding on to it because
they haven't said like I haven't hit
ever so I feel targeting on my helm am I
gonna break that down and get the
ability to use that later cuz I haven't
or do I have to earn everything new it's
like this is why they're doing this on
Wednesday cuz that's another good five
weeks for us to like be able to know or
six weeks really so he's gonna give us
some time lots of questions coming to
one last point before we move on good
you know what I miss
remember when you know think that's a
big list man when they used to add
things into the loop pool secretly and
updated remember you better hold on I
like oh I remember went on it was like
certain little exotics they got updated
or just something they were just sneak
it wouldn't say anything they would just
be in the blue pool you wake up laying
you this immense lay back and it's like
I got this drop it or is it quick you
can do that on console data mining kind
of ruins that yeah PC and PC will ruin
some of that because people find a way
to get the code break it down and
they've got it to a system malloc new
patch broken down like broken back they
know what's in there and they're like
okay here's the new stuff down like if
some way to analyze it I don't know but
I mean people are smarter than I am that
can do that not unfortunately that's the
PC side of it cuz I got a problem real
quick to second rent well five seconds
to listen gambits primarily what we do
is rent we we rent is it back to mom on
it gambits prom PC guys gambit PC guys I
am sick of playing in a lobby of bots
this has happened to me way too many to
the point where I'm not going to thank
you but I'm sitting I'm like what am I
the only person getting moats why is no
one else invading what
and I'm telling if I catch you I'm
snitching I've been snitching I'm an
important oh yeah every table was in
there trying to do the ten matches for
the alt sources are like seven of those
matches were by infused
these bots were like it's great
bro cool moment like blonds you gotta
come up with a better algorithm
everybody got the same papi that's the
funny everyone do this thing okay they
don't actually cuz I've seen some pretty
good ones oh I've seen that will
straight up you supers man that's
hilarious when that happens your butt
kills somebody with a just a random BOTS
over then all of a sudden is super he'll
somebody running at him cuz I think they
got the easy kill and bam then I'll buy
y'all going wrong my experience I'm
gonna be the only one banking I'm gonna
be the only one doing bait and doing all
this stuff
alright cool you get tons that way true
but they get gonna happen then when the
prime you become one person on the other
side wants to wake up and start reckons
I'm like crazy well I lost matches like
I'm like this is so frustrating it's the
only thing I do not miss because that's
so pro the bots in gambit is oh it's
crazy it is it is awful it's awful
please we gotta come up with a subtype
out then we gotta shut him down but if I
see you in gambit and you bitin I'm
snitchin you know so I was like I think
Gorton guard cells actually run into a
rubber-banded controller on ps4 as well
something like that
if they're probably doing like a spin
that's probably rubber-banded controller
or something like that but the bottom on
ps4
you know the funniest thing I've seen
because some people have done it before
they set their controller up like in say
that's like in a box and actually like
an engineer of course they built like a
mechanism to like occasionally tap it or
occasionally tackle jumper so it was
like you know take like a the bouncing
like the what the bobbing like bird that
Bob's in and out of the water was like
occasionally touching the jump button
and then they had like a mechanism that
would just constantly like touch the
controller and move it and it's like
like a smart person spent enough time to
do that and I'm just like you're crazy
oh I don't know how much he stops you to
I mean the only thing I can think of is
that if you repeat the same actions of
Secrets you say I have this well you
ain't move out of a certain space like
and they're all in the back of the melon
oh I've seen some of them like running
down a wall because they butthole oh
yeah just straight forward just burn
just wall running like faith's is 45
degrees down the wall
of the kid so this actually leads
perfectly into what I wanted to talk
about because we have these solstice of
armor grind and as I finished mine how
much have you done on yours
we are literally you're proud of me my
grind it I grind it I I got it done I
was out of town for four days so I
finished mine met last night the bust I
was feeling so good as he said I was
joking but um not do it um so just like
thoughts on the whole process or
thoughts on the grind changes and
literally like you're saying I look like
because I put a video up about this so I
kind of want to ask you first cuz that's
what's been I'm this morning dawns on
the grind for the armor like how could
it change how could they make it better
did you like it did you think it was too
long and we didn't actually get to the
little patch I will say it real quick
they are patching a couple things on it
so just for reference before you go yes
please um the mini bosses that you need
100 oh it's out of 50 shows about to say
that and then completing the final boss
will give you five additional points so
like that actually makes the people
stick around so that being said still
what was your journey like thoughts
changes otherwise stuff like that right
first we start off with the eaz
I love the eaz
I I can't I don't know why I like it so
much
my brother he said it's too much jumping
and I'm a warlock I should hate it like
loof just fine you were like no offense
but you warlocks have like one of the
easier controllable jumps for a small
platform landing of you buddy but cuz
you're like hey I got a lane on this
thing hold on I'm coming down like a
little parachute like me if I get my
momentum going on my shrah hunter if you
don't hit that last jump you missed it
you're falling so I mean honestly for
like specific jumps the world I was
sleeping Jones warlock is ethereal yeah
I will admit that I definitely met that
um here's the eaz I didn't know what to
expect I thought it was really cool I
loved the verticality man I really do I
like that it's just me go out search the
bosses hunt them down you know I'm
saying everyone's splitting up and I
like how strategically ran
it splits up very cool quick-acting
that's super long
you got him saying now let's get back to
your question solstice grind I'll be
honest Eli when we got the first armor
was it the UM what is it green mm-hmm
the trained for green I wasn't expecting
you know some of the things I was asking
I'm like hello grindy for green I'm kind
of nerd you know when you get the blue
like you said that that 100 mini-bosses
Oh like it was rough you know and
basically had to get into a flow of um
multitasking objectives at the same time
so while you're doing strikes you're
doing this why are you doing 25 patrols
or whatever it is I'm Titan I know you
had one Titan Titan bro yeah that's two
about oh hey it's like hit the two
regions bounced the orbit and bounced
back I had three I was doing more repeat
things a lot a lot you know I'm saying
that was a slob um you know it's just it
got to me the thing the thing about it
is the armor was so cool it gave me
motivation to keep pushing because there
were times I'm like I can't today I
gotta try something on mentally I just
need a break from doing this one
activity ten gambit matches you know I'm
saying all this stuff but the hundred
bar almost broke me I literally had
everything done in blue except that last
one I lucked out I got in there with
some blueberry shut up - Adam 23 I don't
know who you are shout out we took
selfies II did he moans together you're
my guy
this guy knew the Cabal mini-boss chief
engineer farm you know the engineer for
I didn't know it he knew he shot me to
slap me and say stop killing the big
boys get over there and I said oh this
is what you're doing and then we just
got into a regular wave come down Scout
him come down at my dojo Toon Boom we
would we would go back we were hiding
around from the big boys we got it done
and even that even with the cheese it's
still a great hour waiting for him if
you just do that how like that was not
balanced well like for a hundred and I
you would think a step like that would
be to master
right like that's a lot to go from blue
to purple so you know it's it's the
armors cool the thought process called
eaz is cool
ryan was a little bit too much and from
my taste
I'm just glad I got it done I feel like
I need a mental vacation Jess when all
of that grinding it's a lot man it's a
lot and um yeah addict asked me right
now cuz he's very tempted on she doesn't
know how he's gonna handle cross savings
in everything ex-wives account but he
really wants to armor so I gave him the
dates and I might do it if you wait
until cross save you've only got like
one week before you know I'm saying you
know life right there that's a no life
so I'm like I'm telling you right now
this grind almost broke me on certain
things you know I even attempted the
master works like it'll be easier after
Tuesday so that's good but so I mean
I've done rambling I mean I just didn't
I just felt it grounds a little a little
too excessive for this book what are
your thoughts you got the video you got
everything what's going on now with you
uh I mean mine was like I mean the boss
changing is good the mini-boss changed
giving and that's the fact that they
some people were killing the many bosses
is that was like the one major outlier
they'd killed many bosses getting the
boss and leave so the fact that they're
changing the main boss to be worth five
points in that is huge because people
will stay in and finish him up which is
yes that's like making sure your
encounter is completed is kind of a
major requirement there when it came to
the ten game it matches this is when I
was thinking about for sure cuz I mean
that was the one I heard a of cares crap
you what you went through as they have
that much I was I had like sweaty game
it matches every time I was like Jesus
what's going on you know you didn't have
to deal with any of cares really not
know people really ha I was getting
worked and I was like low a man on the
totem pole for picking up motes like we
were just like were you playing regular
a prime oh no
yeah I mean I had right place so much
gambit memorize how I got gassed I
thought I was close to delirium
then I read say that you know maybe
that's a bug but anyway yeah man I I
would say if I put a percentage sixty to
seventy percent of my women time of day
did you play um I'm night owl right
so I'm playing you know really you know
2 a.m. 3 a.m. kind of stuff so kind of
might be poor season you know a lot of
people leave their stuff away during
that season so I mean I'm assuming that
could be a little bit too into it but I
even tried you know morning
Eastern's or 10:00 a.m. Levin still you
know now wouldn't I wasn't playing in
primetime Eastern Time after work so
just because that'd be that's opposite
my schedule
yeah but um I don't know how you did
encounter it like I mean and that's all
me Dakota and shad saying she had a big
okay problem depends I think a lot of
that would be more when you played but
my idea is even had a combat there
applied was like yeah it's take make it
active make it like my brother will play
and he'll be like hey I don't have to
win game it matches cuz I'm going to
want to get smoked like 44 to their
prime evils dead it's like this just
sucks like that's awful so I was like ok
no ok so what if in you're like well
what about motes don't make it too many
but let's say you have to kill 200
enemies in gambit and deposit 50 modes
mm-hm make it something where you have
to be active but you don't have to be
amazing if they want you to just be in
the playlist making something where you
can't just sit there and just like be a
lump like I don't want like you can't
just sit there and do nothing but it's
like I might just run around and shoot
stuff even if I'm not like keen on
picking up a lot of motes or I'm scared
I'm gonna lose them or drag my team down
or anything like that make it to where
my ability to go shoot things in the
face is still progressing so it's like
I'm actively helping everybody else can
pick up the motes but if I'm just
running around shooting things I'm
making progress
can I ask why they felt the need for the
orbs to only last like seconds dude I
don't know now I know last season you
could grassi's yeah it lasted like
forever forever like why are they
disappear like I'm running around like a
chicken with his head cut off when I get
that I need the specific solar ones or
whatever is that hmm and I'm just like
what is that I didn't like that decide
and also or I do not drop in gamma prime
they drop it normal but the orbs do not
drop in gambit prime I've even noticed
that they weren't even in there so
that's a weak but for me it was just the
way to make you be active in the
playlist and gambit was the big one I
mean you can go kill guardians and do it
with certain weapons and things like
that
there were things like patrols on one
plane and I'm like oh if you're gonna
make me do patrols make me it'll just be
anywhere at least let me go do dreaming
city tangled short let me at least mix
up the location cuz I know each class
has its own so I'm sure whenever I do a
warlock it's gonna be Titan and I'm just
gonna be like yeah but like 25 is too
many 25 hours insane cuz the two that I
said at least in my video of how to do
the grind the one where you shoot
enemies in the face it's the target
mm-hmm the other one is the compass
where you go pick it up you drive to
location and stay in there those are my
two cuz I'll usually see if the killing
ones there pick up the compass go drive
to the next location stay in there when
that one's done we'll see what's wrong
so I have issues with oka mainly because
if it's like hey go get you know ten
drops from a Scion what if there's only
like three Cylons that spawn yeah like
dude you're just sitting there like wait
like and then if it's since it's in a
patrol space and you can't go do it in a
law sector you're typically fighting
someone else on that same task so that's
why I avoid those like to play because
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be stuck on
this one if I can just go drive Park
Drive park go back to orbit come back
down reset it and try it again all
either shoot things or I'll go drive and
like observe the area like those are my
two going to kill the bosses you're
gonna go so far buried into a lost
sector like the little star the kinda
high values don't do those who don't
yours the collections we have to pick
them up sometimes cool but sometimes no
sale 25 on one planet too many like it
could be 20 patrols on all what if it
was just like you know patrols in
general in general for one but what if
it's like lost sectors patrols or lost
sectors and you can at least like give
me a little more variety like they
didn't touch the lost sectors which is
probably okay we've been forced into a
lot moon for us today with you but I
mean giving you the either or option
that was kind of nice when they're like
gambit or crucible for the green was
nice for both mmm-hmm now some people
would be like hey you need 75 Guardian
kills I had to kill him with arc weapons
and it's like huh what do I use I don't
really have a like did that part no no
but I was okay with like steering you a
little bit because it like makes me be
like what weapon do I want to use
could use waking vigil I ended up using
like a scout rifle for part of that
stuff thunderlord was in their ward
cliff coil system that was just like
naturally done and I know not everybody
loves the killing of Guardians but at
some point I was like if you don't like
game but you don't like I was like if
you don't like gambit go play crucible
if you don't know who I can bit but if
you don't like both I'm sorry you're
screwed I'm sorry you gotta play I
completely agree with you I like the
balance of the either/or there yeah but
I agree like just did the patrols too
excessive
the arm no what you call the 100 just
that broke me bro like I Saturday and I
just I had like 20 at one point and
literally all rest of my blues it done
and I'm sitting there like dreading
going into the eighth now then the other
thing is if someone kills in you didn't
touch that boss you don't get the credit
oh no that's why I literally I'd be up
high and be like hey is there something
up let me tag him with my pulse and then
go work on this one like you know work
our mouth you know so the key was trying
to get to AB like I would try and at
least tag as many bosses or just know
it's like okay I'm melting this one than
seeing what's next like if you had two
people on one side now I'm working the
other it's like I'm getting about yes so
yeah
getting that working and an O Donnell
said approve okay though that's a other
thing about this community we all felt
compelled to grind the living hell out
of this in the first week and it's not
required if you really just want if you
want one set you could spread this thing
out over three weeks true but in in down
but if you want all three it's gonna be
rough like numbers let's keep it real
y'all
oh he saw that's sexy armor that glow
you know you were grabbed when they put
a carrot that is so appealing in front
of you there was no way out way and then
I just said to myself that was it was
like a homework assignment
let me get my studying done let me get
my homework done we got to get it done
let me get my juices the biggest way is
just to mix it up be like I'll do a
little eaz
little yeah that little crucible couple
strikes you gotta mix it up because if
you just burn through like ten game it
matches in a row you're like oh here's
your soul is broken off yeah I just I
just wanted that look and the
back to me what may we really do it was
2.0 compatible right 2.0 compatible I'm
like yes let's go you know I'm saying so
this is the other question that comes up
from this is and Dada Dada had a decent
video just kind of diving into the ever
verse actually the cost of the globe why
am I out of focus yeah I just want to
say yeah I was literally messaging
internally focus alright alright he's
back sorta yeah alright okay
I'm sorry guys that's my hand yeah he is
blurry he's back he's back he's back
he's back so the price of a globe so
each color is either five thousand
bright dust or eight bucks so if you
want all three glows which one set of
armor can't have all three mm-hmm $24 or
15,000 bright best shot at the dados get
a fantastic did on this I just said that
yeah I'm sorry I missed I didn't hear
you say isn't it oh yeah Dada Dada has
the video that literally brings down
this but it's like a fifteen thousand
dust is a lot not even everybody's gonna
have that now I'm not gonna spin my
brightness cuz that's gonna be valuable
so then I'm looking at $24 for glows and
I'm like that like here's the question
is I've got one set done do i grind the
other two and if I do if I do then the
value is at least I have three
characters or three glows it's getting
more use out of it I have one set of
armor for one character I spend $24 on
that one set that you're waving your
hand and you did but that's I mean it
looks really cool I'm sitting there
looking at it but I'm like how was the
other thing I mentioned in the video
that I was like I'm like if you don't
get all three you're spending $24 on one
set of armor and if you're like what if
you go get the raid armor and you take
this thing off there goes your $24 Liz
I felt I was looking at you over there
just like I was like I saw that Bing and
cause here's the thing I was like first
I said well that's too much money right
I said what I'm gonna do is pick once I
get it
pick the subclass you're gonna rock is
you know me I'm out things you're asking
for it all day long of course you
already some night you know what let me
go for I haven't been run out cuz busy I
said this is gonna be my PvE outfit this
is gonna be somewhat picot class right
so I got the fly so I got a new me so
look for that yeah I got an amazing um
Ark outfit that's very regal very love
it right and then I got as far as my own
solar I got a very cool you know I'm
saying whatever but boy I think my PvE
game avoiding any fashion game need to
get up so I was gonna do that so I
bought the $8 whatever right then I saw
someone in the tower with the solar
complete said and I said me and it looks
so much he was just glowing I'm like
he's literally on fire bro and I said
that I'm like well then wow I just gonna
be too
you've - forget the arc if you feel an
arc admit I got caught that's they took
what's ready for me I listen they know
what to do they know what to do and I
will say this it is shouted down it is
excessive and the fact that the bright
dusk and the silver do not correlate
between all these different items is
absolutely close like a Sparrow's a
thousand this is making under this is
three thousand eight dollars three two
four six like it's it's ridiculous
I will say this as obscene this price
would it is cosmetic
we got the choice it's going to Bungie
I'm not gonna beat myself up too crazy
for doing it but it needs to be bouncing
it is just it is just disproportionate
there's no rhyme or reason why these
clothes should be the way they are
you're gonna say they kicked out on us
they know they day they are team they
put together you got it this is great
marketing you got
part of this is to is like hey this is
how the glows early advertised picture
that you gotta buy the animal
there's no way to earn are like whatever
you like okay you have to master work
the entire arm and then you can get the
glow on it mm-hmm not everybody's gonna
be able to master work like we're on
strikes with clanmates one or two person
the other give me a pain in the butt way
to earn it but give me some way to earn
it is yeah I got I got it I got a played
mister to me put my corporate hat on I
gotta make money we got to make the
money they gotta make money but you got
at the end of the day we always say hey
as long as it's not game breaking long
as it doesn't give a competitive
advantage which we have no problem they
given us something that's not game
breaking no compare we just wanted so is
the same thing like I bent the knee I
was like look man this thing is so fired
it looks so amazingly that literally I
had to do it man I just had to listen
the shower deliveries I'm with you guys
I bought a little better
I've gotta shave man listen it goes to
my favorite game my favorites to do I'm
not cheating let them let them live they
they have earned this from me and this
is not forever to me this is the
equivalent you know what this is this is
the ten dollar iron Lord salute that I
bought yeah I know damn well I was
buying it when I saw him put the thing
down boom in the shot said my mom Lord
cop you know I've run I in Lord's pocket
how could I not have the iron Lord emote
for 10 dollars so they caught me they
know how to do it it's good marketing
should they be balanced III kind of I'm
gonna go corporate yeah I think I'm
gonna go on the side of not everything
can be earned in gay they'll never make
money cuz we walk around we're
ridiculous if we out here doing a
hundred mini-bosses
ten that we're doing pristine weird
we're the guys that do this they will
never make money because our grind is
insatiable who we're ridiculous let's be
for us to do this in this short a period
of time
and these some people died got to recap
tis done dear the ones with all three
and the sparrows like holy crap that is
nuts
so three in that piece the one thing
said Fred did bring up mrs. perfect
topic was it's the best number in the
game facts no but like you go back and
look at the other old raid armor with
the glows from crota but they did for
that last like rise of iron like hoopla
finish that is some of the best-looking
armor I've ever seen and the radar
apparently I mean the new raid armor
looks pretty cool like the crannis
article it looks alright with new
designs but they don't have the glows
the ornateness the chromis none of that
stuff is in there this is the only stuff
that looks like that yeah though you're
right you're right I mean you know says
all three done geez geez to see that's
off time sir Bungie in eco shout out to
you you are not you a Bungie as a studio
cannot make money because you you're so
good you are so talented you are such an
amazing grinder they know us they had
they gotta put some stuff behind you
know is it is it kind of you know
corporate yes you know is where we weak
we damn sure we was weak so you could
you help firm did you did you not do it
I'm about any yeah because I just got my
armor today like last night one before I
went to sleep but the question is will I
will you I don't know I don't have to
buy it right now I got time to figure
out if I'm dear well you go [ __ ] yes
this is the one thing that you said
actually do appreciate if I do so $24 I
know the vast majority of that actually
goes straight to Bungie so if I do feel
like supporting Bungie then I'm late you
know what it may not even last me
forever but it's my way of just saying
hey guys keep making the awesome game
and that's that's the one that's the
piece of this change that make some of
those financial choices to be like hey
do I really wanna sure it's for Bungie
it's like I got many hours out of this
game another 24 bucks cool and some of
those easy choices that doubt again this
is my favorite game I literally this
game has dominated my video game career
I've never played a game the way I play
destiny it states that forever game it
it's always something so at this point
for a game to give me this much
enjoyment you know what bro especially
when you do a design like this like I'm
a certain designs I already know throws
money at screen Cognito throws money yes
there's gonna be certain let them make
an Osiris set the one that he had throws
money as there's gonna be certain things
I let them bring back a trial skin
throws money as they gonna get me this
you buy the trials mode man straight up
no shame I yeah
you're like trials this is available for
a separate purchase only how much is it
uh here you go take my wallet
cool right in there it is there it is
bro that's what I get I was weak and I'm
proud so shows given dropping a bomb a
knowledge here parents if you have all
the majestic now correct me if I'm wrong
here you know he goes if you have all
your sets at legendary status then if
you do a two hundred thousand nightfall
in one character it counts for the other
two no count why so like yeah if you are
gonna go hit your master works do them
after you grind the armor so that's yeah
litter that's really really good a nice
didn't actually know that so he ate well
super good advice being trapped on the
last what other little tidbits we've got
like refer friend is going away see if
you haven't done it yet shout out to you
and I we did finish that so that is
because easy friend a hundred bucks
change I think is like perfect but
things like you're changing up gambit so
you have to do just make it to where you
can't be aggressive don't make it or it
you have to win five game matches people
are just gonna be mad but make at or you
can be active I mean killing guardians
and crucible you know you're gonna
probably have to play a little crew some
people like how ideas have to pay a play
pvp and I'm just kind of going I it's
part of the game probably gonna have to
play a little bit they made it low I
mean it was seventy-five it could have
been fifty Gillis
like it could have been fifty a little
lower just to give you a little play
like I don't know play some matches go
invade a little something going babe go
of it you don't want to do crucible get
you gambit get you invasion on a no no
they go do your gambit stuff first see
if you get any invasion
done then if you're done with your
gambit you're like okay I need like 25
more kills okay I'll go play couple
matches crucible you may not be that
good but eventually you will get some
kills yeah shoutouts even my brother you
will still get some kills I played with
you enough you get some chads2 stone
just oh but yeah so I think somehow
somehow we got we got there somehow and
about two hours but mm-hmm
it's been longer and next week you're
gonna be out of mega time oh my god so
much next week so much man I just like I
said I just want to watch some gonna be
monitoring your timeline my answering
how you ingest information I work in the
morning and we get out about 1:30 so I'm
gonna have to literally come home watch
the archive and then probably make a
thoughts video after that but so what's
our official time for the armor it's
10:00 a.m. Pacific armor face explosion
yeah it's 10 a.m. Pacific on the 14th
day or so me it's I gotta stay I'm gonna
be staying up that day for me normally I
go to an article to write possibly or
something so yeah I have to have article
cooked up ready to go
but um yeah this is big this is this is
gonna be game-changing
so I don't know station Tuesday that
we're gonna get the Luke Smith deep dive
into the mind of Bungie and then Friday
special guests and the sixth yes 16th we
got mr. Paul Tassie of Forbes joining us
cannot wait it's gonna be great man
perfect timing it's just gonna be so
much to talk about perfect time to have
a third opinion in here so it's not just
you and I button hits I'm curious to see
his perspectives on certain things -
yeah especially things that we've been
in the middle war and then ask was on
armor - cuz deej said was like hey what
do you want to see was like armor armor
knee armor Paul - he was armor they
may've had a couple other things but
that was in like everybody's list
everybody wants to understand like what
is gonna happen with my vault the old
guys the new stuff how it's gonna work
how to iron it my curiosity is take like
a decimation armor like say Deborah
marmar is armor 2.0 but what if the
destination armor only has five energy
slots max and you can't mean higher what
if the raid is like ten energy slots or
like the in-game stuff is like higher
things like with again no idea but that
would be kind of an interesting it is
like or is the energy just gonna be like
slap master or cores in there and then
you go from like I don't I don't know
how that's gonna wait things they so
many questions this is a very I actually
feel for them I I don't know how to go
ahead us thinking about we we talked
about raid stuff and you know what
happens to remember when they made the
change to the Leviathan and they gave
raid specific mods that you can add what
happens to that what you know what
Benedict and do those go away I'm very
concerned about raid current existing
raid armor and how that translates it
moves forward or not because grade armor
was always in this weird place where
they tried to update it and give it a
little bit of d1 sensibilities but it
never really truly got to where we
wanted it remember like you know how do
we have like opulent mods now but like
these Virgil the past doesn't have
anything different you would get
different mods that could drop but
nothing really basically was all the
mods so like what is happening with mods
armor that whole combination of things
is mm-hmm and then I'm just sitting
there like right now he like he always
teased me because I have no resources
right a lot of it is just because I am
such a a loadout magnet for specific
things like right now I'm going crazy
because I want machine gun reserves on
my class item so I have a scavenger to
reserve perks but I have this for every
type like grenade launcher linear future
fusion shotgun that's how I over here
okay I didn't know if you get down like
that cuz I'm ridiculous like that I mean
I didn't when asked to work every set
but I've got like grenade grenade sniper
sniper yeah why I have so much crap in
my vault is I have the combinations if I
have enhanced this or that like I had an
enhanced sniper targeting with enhanced
I'm using sniper rifle only now let's go
work on her vocre
because I'm sniping like crazy personnel
so oh yeah no that's denny where my load
outs are full I only have nice it's more
armor than weapons we'll say that
Muhammad 11 yet the main thing to is
also the death of the foolish purse
no more Auto rifle reserves no more you
know say like rebels were decent but I
mean seriously like no reserves though
we really run out of balloons side arm
scavenger please just we gotta get rid
of somebody just but I'm looking forward
to hitting on these sneakbo sneakbo Oh
foolish man I cannot wait oh shut up
display say what happens at the powerful
ingress for doing like the flash point
for example do they get armor to point
in it no in them or not
you Dan oh you don't want bow reserved
no I do
must have bowl reserves and bow
scavenger hunting bow yeah it is primary
scavenger seemed stupid because I never
run out thank you that's the whole thing
and that's why I having a choice of leg
hopefully I have other choices on my
chest armor than basic primaries yeah
that's my malicious birth rate has
Genesis on it I just said that earlier
I'm like yeah that's awful that's awful
hit five triple sniper shout out the
Dakotas another would like horrible
perks you can get this is like oh you
guys want to see the god rolls no this
is the facepalm rolls that's gonna be my
new video series facepalm rolls
yeah man so the only thing I've been
doing right now and I don't we gonna
wrap up is I've been doing what you hate
which I've been master working a lot of
by a plus plus weapons very okay with
I'm okay yeah I got a certain one glass
furnace my chin dude orchid ops he was
already came like that I got a sick um
Zenobia with blast radius mod my errant
LSU master doctor shinobi
you'll injure bro it got autoloading
host cluster brahms and zenobia has free
intrinsic tracking because it's a hockey
rocket where are you using the rocket
launcher all the time bro rocket no
sleep no sleep bro yo are you doing
rockets are good play gambit prime go
holler at a primeval envoy I shoot from
one across the map done I'm getting rid
of the invoice so fast to bring up the
big boy it's ridiculous Adobe is my baby
use an obeah and again that you gave me
the tip of Fang Oh max work my friend
it had AI got a god roll dad dad the
role I have is disgusting we already
talked about it but that's another one
but yeah let me tell you right now
shinobi a cluster bomb auto rifle I'm
loading holster because it's a slow
reload and it already had intrinsic what
you call it I'm telling you man that's a
baby truth baby baby truth a little weak
low we tracking weaker tracking but no
transparency tracking so well let's see
I think that's pretty much all I got for
this week as well so hang out in chat
guys I do want to raid somebody
afterwards so let's send you guys over
to somebody else the investing community
something I haven't done I was just like
wrap this thing up I don't actually
spread the load so somebody in the world
of destiny but yeah next week's gonna be
awesome we got I said it multiple times
Luke Smith's article we got the armor
thing we got Paul Tassie coming on so
stay tuned Oh probably a slightly later
start time I think maybe by an hour so
stay tuned for that we will be live we
will be chatting it up we will be having
an awesome time and probably talking for
a hashtag long long point yes sir as
long as we can't ask around at least I
don't wanna abuse back out of respect
but you guys have been awesome thank you
guys chad has been just blowing up the
entire day so thank you guys
if you are new and followers quick go
for shoutouts we got the Reverend plays
first we got Dean Jones Megatron little
Cunha Dave security mischenko McKenzie
Oh probably saying that wrong and the
dude space night two hours ago my user
name is Steve I love that I love that
and the resub zan follows and all that
you guys have been awesome today so
thank you wanted to shout everybody out
enjoy your grind guys space it out don't
know life it if you are going to know
life at least mix up what the hell
you're doing that's important
multitask guys multi-tap multitask for
sure so let's get the audio wrapped and
let's go see who we can raid with all
you guys and make somebody's day so for
episode 68 officially this week not last
week since it didn't quite make it
around it's been awesome
tell them where you're gonna be kognito
yeah Matt Laura Carlito on Twitter and
iron Lords podcast on YouTube there will
be no ILP this Sunday the Lord's will be
at play and YC convention so kind of
like little mini pax that is happening
in New York City my home state so yeah
we're gonna do some coverage as much as
we can want to support these guys it's
gonna be really cool so we'll try to get
some more coverage up on the channel but
we won't have I'll Pete this Sunday we
will return the following Sunday at 1:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time and we will
have a special guest most likely so when
in the business in the making of of
creation of games I can't well yet until
we confirm officially but up yeah it's
gonna be fun man I cannot wait play New
York City this week next Sunday's ILP
will have a developer of hopefully a
game at people interested in so we'll
see what happened very cool and then me
you guys know where to find me got a
video up today just my thoughts about
the grind which some of us on here got
one of about strikes yesterday but you
know where to find me on YouTube right
here streaming when I'm playing on
Twitch and then Twitter and see Pontus
everywhere if you guys haven't subbed
and followed to iron Lords podcast
please do that hit that alert metal sub
and then same for my channel as well
real quick gotta do quick plug quick
look um to giveaway jar if you guys are
Borderlands we going to cook concurrent
Gilligan boys right now Borland's 3 if
you're interested on PC Xbox play we
gotta go please go to the iron Lords
podcast Twitter account we've got that
up going right there as well as Gears 5
if you want it on PC or on Xbox we have
those two running concurrently so we
know September's rough on on the pocket
you know most of you guys can playing
destiny slow
got a little time on the lace and
checked it out and again last plug for
that is thank you guys so much for them
you can cut out for the last plug sorry
sorry for the last plug I don't know
what Mike said well please arm please
Lords of gaming net we really appreciate
all the retweets you guys been doing for
the articles especially stuff especially
really helps us out big time so again go
to Lords of gaming that net check us out
if you like a article comment whatever
do all that good stuff much appreciate
it I'm dumpling
I guess know where to find me as well it
bonds us everywhere so keep being
awesome
enjoy your grind lots of exciting stuff
next week so come back next week same
time one hour later though one week from
today should be an awesome one and
that's about all we got so for episode
68 August 9th this has been the last